Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal, du bist doch ein Suchender, habe ich gehört.
Eine Suche nach.
Ein Taliban.
Oh
Denn hier bei Logbuch Netzpolitik, auch in der hundertvierunddreißigsten Ausgabe sind wir auf der Suche nach Antworten,
Ja, ein Suchender oder ein Schüler, das heißt das, Taliban, das wird er ja wohl gemeint haben. Mal was anderes, kann ich mir irgendwie nicht vorstellen.
Da kommen wir gleich zu, was der.
Ob man, ob der gute Mann überhaupt noch irgendwas meint.
Versteht, beizutragen hat. Ja, ja, es äh äh ist etwas schwierig, so mit der öffentlichen Diskussion und den den Worten, die man so in den Mund nimmt. Wir halten uns ja da immer sehr zurück.
Ja, ja. Wir halten uns da sehr zurück und äh wir überlassen das, das meckern ja lieber den den Hörern und Hörerinnen.
Wie wurde gemeckert?
Wir haben,
Wir haben eine kleinen einen kleinen Hinweis bekommen, dass wir den den von uns in der vorletzten Sendung sehr hoch gelobten Astro TV Heck des äh ausschließlich dem Kollektiv Peng
zugeordnet haben und haben einen freundlichen Hinweis darauf bekommen,
darauf bekommen, dass äh auch die GEW die Gesellschaft zur wissenschaftlichen Untersuchung von Parawissenschaften ähm und von dieser Gesellschaft vor allem die Sektion der Hamburger Skeptiker.
Ähm an der Vorbereitung und Durchführung dieses kleinen, lustigen Auftritts des Clowns äh beteiligt war und ähm da wollen wir natürlich,
auch darauf hinweisen, dass das so ist.
Genau, Ehre, wem ihre äh Gebühr, ich denke, die Gewobag da vor allem den den sachlichen Beistand äh gewertet, ne? In dem Projekt.
Ich wollte gerade, darf man Ehre wem Ehre gebührt sagen oder nicht? Ist oder stand das auch an irgendeinem KZ? Weil bestimmte Sprüche kann man ja deshalb nicht mehr, also die sind ja quasi,
also die die kann man dann nicht mehr sagen.
Und diese so Ehre hat für mich so ein also Ehre wem Ehre gebührt hat für mich irgendwie so eine komische deswegen habe ich das jetzt gerade nicht gesagt.
Ich gucke mal nach, ob ob das irgendwie noch safe ist oder äh ob man da schon irgendwie durchdreht.
Ja, weil meistens die Leute, die über Ehre argumentieren, ne, die haben meistens ähm sonst relativ starken Mangel an an überzeugenden Argumenten.
Ja, das ist in der Tat verbreitet, das stimmt.
Wenn man das irgendwie bei Google sucht, steht das auch sofort in in Runen.
Doch natürlich, ja klar. Nee, dann also ähm ja klar, der Dritte ist direkt irgend so ein Wehrmacht-Helm oder so was.
Meine Güte. Nee, dann habe ich da doch hatte ich das richtige Gefühl, dass ich das lieber nicht sage so.
Tim, wenn du möchtest, gibt's hier gerade im Angebot eine Bomberjacke, wo das hinten in Runen draufsteht.
Ernsthaft?
Ja, das trägt man doch auch ganz gerne, in Großbritannien habe ich gehört, Bomberjacke ist doch da ähm.
Ach komm, jetzt hier nicht so.
Nein, in der Arbeiterklasse ist das doch das.
Also ich habe ja bisher weniger Nazis getroffen als in Deutschland. Das Hotel festhalten.
Okay wir ähm wir schweifen ab. Wir müssen nämlich noch einen ähm ein ein Feedback zur letzten Sendung.
Mit aufnehmen. Der äh Thomas hat sich gemeldet. Ähm weil du in der letzten Sendung noch angesprochen hattest, äh,
wie denn jetzt diese neue FCC-Regulation zur Netzneutralität,
im Hinblick auf den Deal, den comcast mit Netflix hat, zu bewerten ist.
Und das hat äh Thomas für uns aufgeklärt. Ich zitiere,
Nur ein paar kleine Anmerkungen zur Netzneutralität. Es folgt dann ähm größere Papieresrolle. Äh die Netzneutralitätsverletzung im Netflix-Deal bestand in der mutwilligen Drosselung von Netflix Videostreams
im Netz von comcast. Um Netflix in ein
Paype Agreement zu drängen. Durch die neuen FCC-Regeln wäre eine solche Drosselung nicht mehr möglich, derartige Pay Peering Agreements jedoch schon.
Wobei die neuen Regeln auch erstmals den Interconnect-Bereich betreffen, hier aber nur eine Überprüfung durch die FCC erlauben.
Das Gremium, das diese Regeln neu beschlossen hat, besteht aus zwei Demokratinnen, zwei Republikanern und dem. Die Demokratinnen haben mit Wheeler eine Mehrheit gebildet, die Republikaner haben versucht zu filibern.
Die Aufzeichnung ist empfehlenswert. Was in derselben Sitzung übrigens auch beschlossen wurde und auch zur Sendung passt,
ist Community Bray Broad Band. Die FCC hat nämlich früher Regeln erlassen, welche es,
verbieten, ihr eigenes Glas zu verlegen und damit der katastrophalen Netzsituation in vielen Gegenden der USA Abhilfe zu verschaffen,
Glasfaser in öffentlicher Hand mit funktionaler Trennung und echten Wettbewerb am Exist-Mark,
App Excess Markt ist sehr empfehlenswert, erstrebenswert. Ach ja, freuen sollten wir uns
hier aber nicht in Europa sieht es leider äußerst düster aus. Der Rat hat gerade eine katastrophale Position zum Netzneutralitätsgesetz beschlossen und jetzt ist das Europaparlament mal wieder unsere letzte Hoffnung.
Damit nimmt der Thomas schon ein bisschen äh Themen vorweg, die wir gleich auch nochmal kurz behandeln wollen.
Mhm. Also wenn ich das richtig verstehe, äh diese diese Drosselung, die äh Netflix, Entschuldigung, die comcast vorgenommen hat, um Netflix quasi zu erpressen,
die wäre nicht mehr äh zulässig, was ja schon mal ganz okay ist. Ein wäre sehr wohl äh,
unverhinderbar. Ich meine, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, Peering heißt ja im Prinzip erstmal, dass ich überhaupt zwei Firmen an auf eine explizite Datenübergabe einigen. Das äh umfasst ja dann in der Regel auch technische Maßnahmen und ist ja dann ähm,
Ich meine, das ist ja dann sozusagen eine eine Abwägung, wer jetzt hier den größeren Aufwand hat, um dieses Peering durchzuführen.
Von daher ist es wahrscheinlich wirklich schwierig zu regulieren. Da kenne ich mich jetzt so äh in den Realitäten des Peerings nicht so richtig äh gut aus. Äh ja, aber so oder so ist es eine Verbesserung der Situation.
Auf jeden Fall, ja. Wollen wir, wollen wir uns dieser Woche widmen.
Ja. Wollen wir den da gleich bei dem Thema bleiben oder?
Vergangen. Nee, ich habe die, ich habe das jetzt irgendwie andersrum ins Pad geschrieben, aber wie ich kann das, warte, ich kann das ja kurz hochkopieren. Dann bleiben wir bei dem Thema.
Genau, macht's auch vielleicht ganz sinnvoll.
Ja alles seine Ordnung haben. Es muss ja alles seine Ordnung haben.
Also wir haben eine, wir haben eine Durchsage, also Thomas hat's ja schon gesagt, die EU-Staaten haben sich im Rat auf eine gemeinsame Position zur Verbesserung der Netzneutralität geeinigt.
Und zwar gibt es da jetzt ein neues Proposel aus dem,
dem Rat, wo sie sagen, ja, Netzwerk, schön und wichtig, wichtig, wichtig, wichtig. Aber Sonderdienste müssten wir dann schon mal erlauben.
Du kannst jetzt nochmal sagen, was der Rat ist. Du machst ja mit Fokus Europa den Europa-Podcast. Also weißt du, was der Europarat? Der der EU-Rat oder Europarat, wie ich ja äh verstehe das aber alles nicht. Du kennst dich da besser.
Ja genau, also es ist nicht der Europarat, der hier gemeint ist, sondern hier ist der Rat der EU gemeint. Ja.
Der auch Europäischer Rat genannt wird. Also es gibt sozusagen den Europarat,
Und es gibt den Europäischen Rat, genauer Rat der Europäischen Union. Der Europarat ist ein äh auch Russland, die Türkei, komplett Skandinavien, Island, also nahezu wirklich
ähm europäischen Länder, ich glaube nur mit der Ausnahme von Weißrussland,
äh beinhaltendes äh Gremium, was halt ja in Fragen von Europa diskutiert. Das ist mir so ein Diskussions äh so eine Diskussionsrunde wie OECD auch. Der Rat der Europäischen Union ist eine der drei Standbeine,
des EU des politischen EU-Systems, des Parlamentes, das was gewählt wird, die Kommission ist die, die berufen wird und der Rat ist nichts anderes als die Vertretung der nationalen Regierungen in der EU, das heißt,
wenn vom Rat der EU die Rede ist, dann ist von unserer Bundesregierung und anderer Regierungen in Europa die Rede.
Also sozusagen das das ist sozusagen der Wille der Regierungen, ne?
Tja.
Und die wollen aber Netzneutralität jetzt wieder nicht. Und der des Taliban Parlament äh das Europaparlament, in dem sich quasi die ganzen gewählten Tallieb Talibe befinden.
Dass ähm das möchte jetzt Netzneutralität wieder in in Reihenform haben, ne?
Also da wird auf jeden Fall jetzt grade gezankt und wir haben jetzt schon mehrfach die die Anspielung äh über über die Talibe.
Und da können wir jetzt, glaube ich, auch so zu einer der also es gibt ja immer mal wieder, ich glaube so immer mal wieder kommt ein Politiker daher und.
Zeigt so wirklich, dass er so richtig gar keine,
gar keine Ahnung von dem von dem Themenbereich hat, mit dem er äh äh da, der ihm anvertraut wurde, ne. Das letzte Mal, ich glaube, wo wir so ein Niveau hatten, das war ähm,
Ansgar Heveling in seinem Artikel im Handelsblatt, oder? Also so lange ist das.
Ja ja.
Netzgemeinde, ihr werdet den Krieg verlieren. Auch so ein also eine ein Mensch.
Vielleicht fangen wir da mal an. Ich finde das also unsäglich. Ich finde das unsäglich. Ähm die diese politischen,
Auseinandersetzung über die Zukunft unserer Gesellschaft zu diffamieren als ein als ein Krieg. Das schon mal sowieso,
unabhängig davon äh bin ich natürlich auch der Ansicht, wie wie sagt man so schön. Äh Politik ist die Fortführung des Krieges mit anderen Mitteln. Insofern müssen wir uns da vielleicht auch nichts vormachen. Natürlich geht es hier auch um Kämpfe,
von von Interessengruppen, aber bis jetzt haben sie uns halt noch nicht so weit gebracht, dass wir äh wieder zu den Waffen greifen. Ähm.
Günther Oettinger hat jetzt eine eine Rede gehalten zum zur Taliba äh zu zu Netzneutralität.
Total die Bahn.
Ich weiß nicht, schaffst du das, die mal kurz einzuspielen oder ähm so muss ich jetzt, bin ich jetzt gezwungen, das zu zitieren.
Ähm wenn du mir mal ein Link gibst, weil ich habe das jetzt hier nicht vorbereitet.
Oje. Ähm ja, dann machen wir komm, das machen wir aber trotzdem. Man muss das auch äh wenn du auf Netz Netzwerk Org einfach einmal Oettinger suchst, dann ist da das YouTube Video eingedingst.
Findest du das.
Ich bin dabei, leider ist hier mein Netz gerade etwas schwierig dieser Wolf im Schafspelz oder was? Nee.
Nein, nein, nein, suche Oettinger OETT INGER. Äh und dann findest du diese Rede
Ich kann ja in der Zwischenzeit schon mal erzählen, dass dass Andre vor kurzem dann festgestellt hat, dass die öffentlich dokumentierte Version dieser Rede ähm,
massiv verändert wurde. Ähm das passiert häufig bei so äh Reden, dass man irgendwie ähm.
Dass sie, dass sie verschriftlichte Version dann so um um bereinigt wird und so und das häufig reden ja auch zu Protokoll gegeben werden, aber in dieser wurde jetzt halt rum editiert. Wenn man sie jetzt gleich hört.
Äh weiß man auch wahrscheinlich wieso.
Es ist wirklich.
Weiß nicht, was man dazu sagen soll. Also.
Also es ist äh wie sagt man so schön? Ja, also es.
Aktivistin in diesem Bereich als oder also da überhaupt diesen Begriff Taliban zu verwenden, das äh.
Das zeugt wirklich von ähm von absolutem Mangel an.
Qualifikation und auch einen absoluten Mangel an an Sensibilität äh für das Thema, ne?
Ja, absolut.
Aber wollen wir uns mal, wollen wir uns mal dem widmen, was der, was der gute, gute Mann sagt? Also er sagt.
Netzneutralität ist gleich Taliba an.
Weil perfekte Gleichmacherei. Er wirft vor, dass man von der bösen Industrie sprechen würde, aber es geht ja gar nicht um die Industrie, sondern um unser Leben.
Und jetzt hat er zwei zwei wichtige Beispiele, warum wir uns also von der Netzneutralität verabschieden müssen als Taliban. Und zwar,
Telemedizin, also eine Fern-OP, die das Uniklinikum,
Weil es ja nicht ausgelastet ist mit seinen Patienten, dann über das Internet ähm noch im im Dorfkrankenhaus macht, nach einem schweren Unfall.
Das ist natürlich so ein eine Standardsituation des des,
des Gesundheitswesens, ne. Also das kennen wir jeden Tag, ja.
Laufend.
Laufend, also ich meine.
Unabhängig davon, dass man selbst, egal, wie du das Internet beschneidest und so du dich niemals,
mit mit so etwas auf eine reine äh auf eine normale Internet äh Leitung verlassen könntest. Ja, egal, was du da was du da an Prioritäten drin hast und so. Dafür ist eine Internetverbindung einfach nicht
gemacht.
Und genau deshalb werden solche Fernschaltungen, wenn sie gemacht werden, auch über einfach äh dedizierte äh feste Leitungen gemacht, ne. Da wird also dann da liegt halt ein.
Eine Verbindung, über die diese beiden Orte miteinander verbunden sind auf dieser Verbindung läuft nichts anderes und dies nur für diesen
Zweck eingerichtet. Also es ist absoluter Unsinn, es wäre absoluter Wahnsinn, es mit keinem keiner Form des des kaputtregulierten und kaputt kontrollierten Internets vereinbar ernsthaft,
Operationen an Lunge, Herz und Kreislaufgefäßen über das Internet durchzuführen. Ist absolut lächerlich und,
nun wirklich auch nicht,
Einer der Anwendungsfälle, die wir in dieser Welt ähm heute und in der Zukunft ähm für das Internet sehen werden. Ähm das Gleiche gilt ja für dieses sehr, sehr krude Beispiel, dass ausgerechnet das Internet.
Jetzt einen Fahrer darüber informieren soll, dass von rechts jemand kommt.
Also auch das ist ja wieder eine Information, ja.
Ist geil.
Ich meine, von rechts kommt jemand,
Jetzt gibt's natürlich jetzt könnte man überlegen, so jetzt sind wir wir sind jetzt hier Ingenieure und wir sagen, wir möchten etwas bauen, was jemanden davor dafür warnt, dass dass von rechts jemand kommt. So das Nächste, was mir einfallen würde, wäre halt so ein einfaches Videosystem,
ähm oder so ein Entfernungsmessersystem, das einfach sagt, von rechts nähert sich etwas sehr schnell, ähm halt an.
Das gibt es auch schon heutzutage in Autos, das heißt einfach Sensoren, die sind direkt in das Auto äh verbaut und nirgendswo anders dürfte das drin sein, weil das Internet, also was auch immer damit äh über das Internet mit einem sprechen könnte, kein anderes,
Gerät dieser Welt könnte besser beurteilen, ob da von rechts was kommt als das eigene Auto. Und das ist auch viel äh schneller in der Lage, darauf zu reagieren, nämlich
und nicht erst nach irgendeinem und irgendeinem keine Ahnung, ein Rauter, der sich im Kreis dreht und irgendwie die Pakete erstmal fünf Sekunden lang baff hat und so, also das ist halt also das ist sehr interessant, dass dass er das auch einfach
dass der das glaubt.
Vor allem dat glaubt ihr doch selber nicht. Und schon schaut es doch auch mal schaut mal das.
Klärt und der glaubt das einfach.
Das mag sein, das ist ein tragischer Fall, aber schau dir mal das schau dir mal das die Internetversorgung an, ja? Ich meine, du hast irgendwie du wenn du irgendwie mit deinem Auto rumfährst, ja und da kommt einer von rechts, das passiert dir, wenn du Pech hast im Etschland,
da ist da hat die Antenne, die da irgendwo in den Karpaten steht, hat überhaupt nicht die Kapazität, die Autos, die da alle langfahren,
nur zu pinnen und und eine TCP Verbindung mit ihnen aufrecht zu erhalten,
Ja, also da kannst du, da brauchst du jetzt nicht davon zu kommen, dass da dass da irgendwie in Echtzeit dich warnt, von rechts kommt einer. Vor allem woher weiß das Internet das denn? Weil alle da dranhängen oder was? Also es ist eine absolut eine absolut krude,
äh ein ein absolut cooles Beispiel, ja. Ähm hinzu kommen ja dann noch diese beiden Beispiele, ja ähm.
Der Bengel, das finde ich so schön, ja. Das Kind ist nämlich auch scheiße. Für das Kind hat der auch nichts als als Verachtung über und tituliert es als Bengel, weil es Games spielt
ja? Der Bengel sitzt hinten rechts oder links und spielt Games.
Ja und da ist es auch,
das mal ein paar Sekunden später äh äh seinen Bildschirm aufbaut, ne. Sechzig Fremds pro Sekunde äh braucht ja heutzutage kein Mensch mehr, da reichen ja irgendwie sechzig Bilder pro Stunde. Muss auch ausreichen. Früher hatten wir ja auch nicht mehr, ne? So sein.
Welche Spiele kommen denn bitte aus dem Internet? Also das verstehe ich überhaupt nicht.
Na ja, da würde mir jetzt schon einiges einfallen, mein Freund.
Bitte dich, Online Games ist ein riesen riesen Ding und gerade kollaboratives Spielen und warum sollte das Kind auf dem Rücksitz
äh nicht äh irgendwie, es muss ja jetzt nicht unbedingt ein, aber dass man irgendwie ein vernetztes Spiel mit anderen Leuten spielt und dass er selbstverständlich dann die Reaktionszeiten essenziell sind für die Qualität dieses Spieles und damit auch für die Qualität
Spieleherstellers und damit auch für die Qualität dieser der Spielebranche, die im Übrigen eine aufstrebende Branche ist, in dem digitalen,
Economy-Bereich, für den Herr Oettinger zuständig ist im Übrigen, ja? Und äh das scheint ja wohl noch nicht so ganz verstanden zu haben, dass er im Prinzip hier genau das Gegenteil von dem sagt, was äh eigentlich seine Aufgabe wäre.
Richtig und genau die Spielehersteller sind natürlich diejenigen, die ähm genau deshalb ihre Protokolle, über die die Spiele miteinander reden, ähm so schmal und und schnell wie möglich gestalten.
Und sind auch die allerersten,
die bereit wären, für eine ähm Bevorzugung ihrer Dienste ähm äh zu bezahlen, ja?
Die brauchen um die Qualität ihrer Dienstleistung sicherzustellen, dieses Echtzeit äh Erlebnis und das wären die ersten.
Die da rein investieren würden. Die ersten, die sagen würden, ah, es gibt irgendwie garantierte schnellere Pinks oder sowas.
Wunderbar. Wir sind die Ersten, die das kaufen.
Hm.
YouTube würde eher ähm ähnlich wie äh Netflix über
über Drosselung erpresst werden, um irgendwie für sein Volumendurchsatz zu bezahlen. Ich mein, das sind ja die Beispiele, die wir jetzt sehen, ja? Also ich meine, wir erleben gerade
Neutralitätsverletzung durch Musikstreaming-Dienste, wir ähm erleben sie durch,
oder gegenüber von Videostreaming-Diensten, die ähm daran gehindert werden, die Daten äh zu den Kunden bestimmter Netzanbieter zu schieben. Das sind genau,
diese Fälle, die beobachten wir heute. Wir sehen Netzneutralitätsverletzungen in Mobilfunknetzen, die ihre äh die versuchen, ihre Kunden an der Nutzung von ähm Skype und anderen Voice-over IP Diensten zu hindern. Das sind alles,
die aktiven äh die aktuellen Probleme, die wir in diesem Bereich haben.
Und die wir auch in der Zukunft haben werden. Keine Sau wird jemals über das Internet eine ernstzunehmende leben, lebensgefährliche Telemedizinoperation machen. Das wird immer über eine dedizierte Leitung gehen, weil alles andere
absolut fahrlässig wäre und keine Sau wird sich Echtzeit,
aus dem Internet darüber warnen lassen, dass von rechts jemand kommt. Das Einzige, was eventuell eine Rolle spielen könnte, in in diesem Szenario, ich hatte das vor zwei, drei Folgen mal angesprochen. Wenn demnächst der Google
alle unsere Autos autonom steuert.
Dann wird das Internet dafür sorgen, dass niemals mehr ein Auto von rechts in ein anderes Pferd
aber nicht über eine Echtzeitleitung, sondern darüber, dass die Autos Stunden im Vor oder Minuten im voraus schon wissen, wie sie fahren müssen, weil sie Buffern, damit sie nämlich genau nicht Echtzeit abhängig sind.
Ja, also das ist ähm.
Es ist wirklich, es ist sowas von zum, zum, zum Heulen, ja, dass ein Mensch sich auf dieses argumentative und auf dieses inhaltliche Niveau herabbegibt,
der eine sehr wichtige Rolle im europäischen politischen ähm Geschehen spielt. Und das ist
Durch nichts entschuldbar und die Hörerinnen und Hörer, die jetzt darauf gehofft haben, dass ich mich auch nur in die Nähe dieses Niveaus begebe und mich da in irgendeiner Form.
Da zurück warnte die muss ich da leider enttäuschen. Also das ist durch nichts mehr zu entschuldigen.
Ja man muss auch sagen, dass das natürlich dieses auch dieses Wort Taliban, ja, also abgesehen davon, dass ich das überhaupt gar nicht so richtig.
Ich verstehe überhaupt gar nicht seine seine Gedankenkette erschließt sich mir wirklich nur sehr sehr eingeschränkt, aber was auch immer dazu geführt haben sollte, dass
dieses Wort genommen hat, ja? Also was er ja im Prinzip, also erstmal finden auch ein anderes Wort Uris zweifelhaft, nicht nur äh Taliban, ja, das ist ja.
Das macht's eigentlich schon wieder so ein bisschen lächerlich, aber genau, diese Gleichmacherei, ja, also äh ist sozusagen auch noch zur Herabzuwürdigung, dass man gleiche Chancen,
Chancengleichheit äh äh also dass man das sozusagen fordert
das ist auf einmal ganz furchtbar und zwar furchtbar in einem in dem selben Level, wie es furchtbar ist, Leuten äh den Kopf abzuschneiden oder
ähnliche vergleichbare Maßnahmen oder Kulturgüter zu zerstören oder so. Ich weiß ja nicht, was er so im im Sinne hat, wenn er irgendwie an die Taliban denkt, aber er muss da irgendwie mal äh tolle Ferien in Afghanistan gehabt haben.
Ja, also es äh ist wirklich unmöglich. Ähm,
Ich glaube, dass er, also was äh der der Oettinger, der ist natürlich auch in so einem Alter, wo man über Jahrzehnte ähm im politischen und und in wirtschaftspolitischen.
Fragen. Ähm.
Damit damit arbeiten konnte, dass man eben dann äh Kommunismus, Stalinismus, äh geh doch nach drüben oder so, ne. Das ist ja noch alles so. Das ist so wurde der ja groß, der der Mann.
Und ich glaube, dass ihm einfach klar ist, dass er ähm,
er hat wahrscheinlich versucht, mit der Zeit zu gehen und und das, was er, was er wie er seit Jahrzehnten,
Politik betreibt und Menschen,
ja, täuscht über über die tatsächlichen, rationalen seines politischen Engagements, ähm dass er das einfach nur in die heutige Zeit heben wollte und gesagt hat, ja,
Gleichmacherei ist Taliban. Fertig. So, viel viel mehr wird ja darüber nicht nicht nachgedacht haben. Ich meine, das sind untragbare Personen, auch schon vorher gewesen. Ähm,
aber ja, also ich bin.
Politik ist ist wichtig, da werden echt echte Entscheidungen getroffen, die unsere Gesellschaft betreffen und unser Nachhalt, unser Zusammenleben nachhaltig beeinflussen. Und Menschen.
Die sich, die nach so vielen Jahren in der Politik ähm noch zu solcher, solchen Ausdrucksformen,
Solchen Argumentationsketten ähm greifen. Die haben da wirklich nichts verloren. Die haben da wirklich nichts verloren. Das macht, füllt mich mit großer Sorge.
Genau, also Herr Öttinger, wir sind etwas unzufrieden mit ihrem Statement, um's mal äh ganz politisch auszudrücken.
Ja, kommen wir zu ähm erfreulicheren äh Themen. Ach nee, erstmal haben wir noch weniger erfreulichere Themen. Äh die Störerhaftung lässt uns nicht in Ruhe.
Das ist auch etwas, was wir, glaube ich, in der letzten äh Folge schon angesprochen haben.
Wir schon, ja.
Wo es um den da hatten wir, da haben wir über den Gesetzesentwurf gesprochen äh und da war er aber noch nicht wirklich offiziell.
Und jetzt äh haben wir, haben wir den Salat, der äh,
Gesetzesentwurf zur Störerhaftung wurde feierlich angekündigt, weil man ja jetzt Rechtssicherheit für äh die Betreiber von WLANs schaffen möchte, nämlich.
Wie sie auch im Koalitionsvertrag versprochen war, ne? Da wurde gesagt, wir werden Rechtssicherheit schaffen für äh für die Anbieter von WLANs und das heißt, äh in diesem Fall ja,
du kommst recht sicher,
in den Knast, wenn du's machst, ja. Das ist jetzt die, die Rechtssicherheit, die da geboten wird und indem man einfach sagt, okay, ähm Personen, die anderen über ihr WLAN Zugang zum Internet gewähren. Ähm.
Werden nicht für die Rechtsverletzung dritter haften. Da müsste jetzt eigentlich ein Punkt hin,
Aber da ist, kommt jetzt ein Komma. Wenn sie zumutbare Maßnahmen zu Verhinderung solcher Verstöße ergriffen haben. Zumutbare Maßnahmen ist natürlich ein sehr interessanter, interessante Formulierung hier. Ähm, das könnte heißen,
Zumutbare Maßnahme ist ähm dass das WLAN ist eben ähm,
verschlüsselt und äh du kannst, du musst dich anmelden, das könnte aber natürlich auch heißen, dass man ähm,
sich bemüht, Torens zu sperren und ähm einschlägige Webseiten zu sperren.
Ähm aber hier wird also in diesem Gesetz wird gesagt, äh man muss den Anschluss verschlüsseln und man darf den Zugang nur solche Nutzerinnen und Nutzern ermöglichen, die zuvor eingewilligt haben, keine Rechtsverletzungen zu begehen.
Ja? Okay, ähm das macht man bei den meisten Hotspots. Also für einen Hotspotbetreiber ähm ändert sich nämlich hier gar nichts. Ähm rein private,
nicht geschäftsmäßige WLAN-Anbieter. Also, Freifunk. Ähm oder ich oder,
Du, wenn du ein offenes WLAN äh bereitstellst, wenn du Gäste hast oder so.
Sollen laut dem Entwurf nur dann in den Genuss der Haftungsfreistellung kommen, wenn sie darüber hinaus auch die Namen der Nutzerinnen und Nutzer kennen.
Das heißt, sie du musst,
du kannst ein freies WLAN bereitstellen, klar, aber du musst bitte die Person, die es nutzen, namentlich registrieren,
Damit du nicht nachher sagst, oh ja, das war irgendjemand, der in meinem WLAN war, der hat jetzt da offenbar irgendwas runtergeladen. Na ja, ich bin halt äh Internetprovider.
Ich, ich, ich tue den Menschen um mich herum etwas Gutes und ich habe im letzten Jahr, was weiß ich, ähm,
Terabyte oder im letzten Monat ein Terra bei Traffic durch mein WLAN geschoben,
und offenkundig war da jetzt auch irgendwie fünfzig MB bei, äh die irgendwie die Rechte von Universal Music Music verletzt haben.
Ähm das geht eben nicht, ja? Das da da wiegt da wiegt das Interesse von Universal Music hier eine äh Kosten bewährte Abmahnung äh rauszuschicken ähm höher,
und aus dem Grunde wird es eben nicht mehr in Ordnung sein, einfach sein Internet mit anderen Leuten zu teilen.
Ich habe ja so ein bisschen die Vermutung, dass diese schwammigen Formulierungen so eigentlich nicht überleben dürften. Das äh ist ja schon wieder so in der Kategorie Leistungsschutz äh äh Recht, ja, wo von so äh geringen Textstellen äh kleinsten wie hieß das noch mal?
Kleinstmöglichen Zitaten oder sowas
zumutbare Maßnahmen, also es ist halt nicht definiert, die Maßnahmen müssten halt mal definiert werden, weil was was auch immer eine zumutbare Maßnahme ist, äh wer beurteilt, was zumutbar ist. Ja, ich kann ja sagen, also mehr ist mir leider nicht zuzumuten, könnte ich ja auch sagen.
Also und äh interessant finde ich auch die Formulierung, dass man den Namen der Nutzerinnen und Nutzer kennt
Also ich meine, kein Problem, wenn die Abmahnung reingeflattert kommt, dann schicke ich ihnen den Namen, ja? Das war eine Rübezahl und Hasibärchen dreiundzwanzig. Die äh haben mir ein bisschen gewütet, aber die äh hat mir auch gesagt, die machen's nie wieder.
Sie ist nicht von Identität die Rede. Ich will jetzt hier nicht äh Picking äh betreiben und sagen, äh so ist das ja komplett äh äh sinnlos und das äh ähm könnten wir schon durchaus mal äh einführen lassen. Das geht natürlich in der Form eigentlich überhaupt nicht
Weil es halt einfach das eigentliche Problem, was wir derzeit haben, nicht nur nicht löst, sondern eigentlich auch noch verschlimmert. Ja, also derzeit gibt's halt keine Rechtssicherheit, weil man theoretisch nämlich angeklagt werden kann und äh mit dieser Variante äh
ist es sozusagen auch überhaupt nicht möglich, äh in der gewünschten Formnetz bereitzustellen, nämlich einfach hier, Netz hast du, mach, ja, sondern man ist gezwungen
Verkehrsverhinderungsmaßnahmen zu ergreifen, wie halt einfach, da sind wir uns, glaube ich, auch einig, die einfach,
sterben haben, ja, ist einfach, es geht einfach gar nicht, dass es die überhaupt gibt. Klar, die werden uns noch eine Weile verfolgen, aber toller macht es sie eben auch nicht,
Und ich meine, was soll denn überhaupt dieses man will nicht sofort äh zuvor ein, keine Rechtsverletzungen zu begehen,
Hallo, ich meine, wir leben hier in einem Rechtsstaat. Das ist der. Ja, davon,
kann ich bei jedem Menschen ausgehen, dass er nicht vorhat, Rechtsverletzungen zu begehen. Ich meine, wenn man irgendwie so daherkommt, da könnte man jetzt auch äh äh
auf der offenen Straße die Leute halt auch am laufenden Meter anhalten und sagen, ja sie dürfen jetzt hier leider nicht über die Ampel gehen, bevor sie nicht äh.
Gesagt haben, dass sie jetzt nicht in den nächsten zehn Minuten irgendwelche strafbaren Handlungen vollkommen absurd.
Du du reist in die USA ein, da musst du jedes Mal sagen, dass du nicht planst, den Präsidenten zu ermorden oder.
Also das ist äh das musst du denen schriftlich geben. Was meinst du, dass du bei der Einreise in in verschiedene Länder alles für einen Mist unterschreiben musst? Ja, ähm.
Und dann wird, ne, wie wir wissen, der einzige Präsident der USA, der je erschossen wurde, wurde vom Amerikaner erschossen, ne? Egal.
Angeblich.
Was hier interessant ist, ist,
Abwägung, die da getroffen wird, ne, also schau dir an, was für ein volkswirtschaftlichen Mehrwert du du durch so eine flächendeckende, vernünftige äh Versorgung mit Internet schaffen könntest, ja.
Und die Interessen einiger weniger namentlich hier der rechte Inhaber und das darf man nicht vergessen, derjenigen, die mit,
Hotspot angeboten, Geld verdienen wollen, ja? Die Deutsche Telekom hat 'ne nicht.
Nicht zu verachtende Anzahl von kostenpflichtigen Hotspots im Land verteilt und ähm Kabel Deutschland ebenso.
Also wenn die Deutsche Telekom und Kabel Deutschland überall Hotspots hinstellen.
Mit denen sie Geld verdienen wollen, dann ist natürlich das letzte, was die wollen, dass auf einmal eine Reihe von Idealisten Eden.
Mit ihrer Dienstleistung konkurriert und zwar für umme. Einfach nur aus Idealismus. Ich meine, das Letzte, was du möchtest, wenn du ein Geschäftsfeld beackern möchtest.
Ist das irgendjemand kommt und dir kostenlose Konkurrenz macht.
So, das ist einmal deren Seite und natürlich die Rechteinhaber QTerrorisieren, das Internet seit es das gibt.
Das ist jetzt nix Neues, dass die äh gerne möchten, dass jeder Internetnutzer identifizierbar ist. Und.
Interessanterweise muss man da auch berücksichtigen. Die wollen natürlich gar nicht unbedingt ähm,
dass jeder äh dass sie jeden Nutzer identifizieren können, damit er keinen Mist mehr baut, sondern die wollen, dass sie jeden Nutzer identifizieren können, damit sie die abmachen können. Ja, also diese dieses,
Die Abmahnindustrie trocken zu legen ist überhaupt nicht deren Interesse. Die wollen ja durchaus weiter erhalten. Ist ja ein lukrativer ähm lukrativer Zweig, der ähm der Geld einbringt. Ja,
Naja, in diesem, also diesen beiden Interessen wird hier,
eben ein ein großes Wohl der Allgemeinheit geopfert. Und ich denke, die Abwägung, die hier an dieser Stelle getroffen wird, ist wirklich eindeutig falsch.
So, dann haben wir aber noch einen Teil in diesem in diesem Gesetzesentwurf oder in der in der in der in der in der Debatte, nämlich.
Die Hosting Provider. Auf darüber hatten wir gesprochen, ne? Was machen wir mit Cloud-Diensten, wie Dropbox, YouTube? Äh wenn die.
Rechtswidrige Inhalte ihrer Nutzer veröffentlichen. Und die aktuelle äh die aktuelle Regelung ist, sie sind dafür nicht verantwortlich, solange ihnen die Rechtswidrigkeit nicht bekannt ist,
und sie die Inhalte umgehend entfernen, sobald sie Kenntnis davon bekommen. Also, äh irgendjemand ähm.
Schreibt bei Logbuch Netzpolitik ein Kommentar, verletzt damit die Rechte eines anderen. Ähm dann haften wir oder der Tim,
nicht dafür,
solange Tim davon keine Kenntnis hat. Sobald aber dann der derjenige oder diejenige Partei, deren Rechte verletzt wurden, den Tim darüber in Kenntnis setzt, ab dann.
Haftet er und muss,
diese rechtswidrigen Inhalte dann entfernen. Und entsprechend haben natürlich auch diese Anbieter dann Schnittstellen, die es ermöglichen, äh die es den Rechteanbietern,
nahezu automatisiert ermöglichen, äh Inhalte dort wieder zu entfernen.
Und da wird gesagt, na ja okay, hat die Regierung jetzt einen Gesetzesentwurf gemacht, wo sie sagen.
Kenntnis soll bei Gefahr geeigneten Diensten künftig vermutet werden. Das heißt, wenn du.
Ein Dienstbetreiber, der relativ oft dadurch auffällt, dass dort ähm Urheberrechtsverletzendes Material äh ausgetauscht wird. Dann drehen wir diese.
Annahme, diese Unschuldsvermutungsannahme um und sagen, du bist grundsätzlich.
Hast du davon auszugehen, dass das, was bei dir hochgeladen wird, illegal ist und dann,
ähm haftest du auch sofort? Ähm das heißt.
Dienste, die hauptsächlich dadurch genutzt werden, haften, äh die hauptsächlich durch äh die hauptsächlich für illegales Fileshering genutzt werden, haften automatisch, auch ohne Kenntnis. Und das Gleiche soll gelten, wenn sie ähm.
Eine geeignete Maßnahme die Gefahr einer rechtsverletzenden Nutzung fördern. Zum Beispiel.
Ja, was was ist eine geeignete Maßnahme, die gezielt die Gefahr einer rechtsverletzenden Nutzung fördert? Zum Beispiel, wenn du das so machst, wie äh mega mit ihr mit ihrem neuen Dienst, wo sie sagen,
Das, was bei uns hochgeladen wird, wird schon auf eurer Seite verschlüsselt, damit wir nämlich plausible,
plausibel leugnen können, dass wir die Inhalte kennen. Und in der Lesart dieses Gesetzes ist genau das eine Maßnahme, die,
den Dienst besonders geeignet macht für rechtsverletzende Nutzung. Man könnte sagen, dass er genau das fördert.
Ebenso sind Dienste betroffen, wenn sie mit der Nichtverfolgbarkeit von Rechtsverstößen werben? Oder keine Möglichkeit vorhalten, um rechtswidrige Inhalte zu entfernen.
Ja? Mit anderen Worten. Also, ne, ich hatte das Beispiel mega. Wenn du dich jetzt hinstellst und sagst, wir unsere Server stehen in Russland und äh wir können euch nicht verfolgen oder garantiert anonyme Uploads oder so. Zack.
Sofort auf der Liste.
Ja, dann bist du Apple ja eigentlich auch gleich auf diese Liste kommen, weil die sagen ja im Prinzip genau dasselbe.
Ja, Apple.
Ne, somit hier irgendwie, wir können der Polizei nichts geben, weil wir haben nichts, wir können's ja selber nicht lesen so. Stimmt zwar auch nicht so richtig, aber zumindest behaupten sie das.
Ja, aber genau klar, ne, in dem Bereich äh äh in dem Bereich geht das. Also hier werden jetzt die Daumenschrauben angezogen und ist natürlich,
Natürlich macht das Sinn, wenn du sagst, okay, wenn du aktiv dafür wirbst, dass dein Dienst für Illegale Tätigkeiten.
Genutzt werden soll, dann bis dann tatsächlich aktiv und du ziehst da einen kommerziellen Nutzen draus
und ähm das geht so nicht. Dann dann wirst du einfach haftbar gemacht und schon lässt du das sein, weil dann kriegst du für jede Datei äh für jede Urheberrechtsverletzende Datei, die bei dir liegt, kriegst du eben die Abmahnung
weil du dich eben weigerst, ähm die Nutzer ans Messer zu liefern und ähm damit hast du dem Anbieter natürlich relativ schnell,
den Spaß an der ganzen Angelegenheit genommen. Beziehungsweise du hast eben den Spaß daran genommen überhaupt noch irgendwelche
modernen äh Dienste des einundzwanzigsten Jahrhunderts in Deutschland zu betreiben, weil sie natürlich dann einfach derartiger Legislatur einfach entgehen wollen, klar.
Also das ist ja wieder nur so ein Punkt, wo du siehst, okay, damit schaffst du eine recht Unsicherheit, beziehungsweise eine.
Eine Rechtssicherheit, nämlich du kommst in den Knast, wenn du das machst, für jeden Plattformanbieter und Betreiber,
und die werden natürlich dann entsprechend sind dann gezwungen abzuwandern, um um ihre legitimen Geschäftsinteressen ähm durchsetzen zu können und äh für die,
die sie dem Markt machen, für die eine Nachfrage besteht, ähm dann eben auch einen einen rechtlichen Rahmen zu finden, indem sie diese Angebote betreiben können.
Ja. Also ich habe so auch so.
War das jetzt unser oder.
Ja, das ist hier so ein bisschen unser Leck. Wir haben leider gerade wirklich eine extrem äh schlechte Verbindung, die, glaube ich, auf beiden Seiten von äh mangelhaften äh mangelhafter Netzneutralität äh zerstört wird. Ja.
Ich habe aber, ich habe extra ein schönes VPN hier gemacht, diese komischen.
Ja, aber das ist einfach äh die die Provider, die verhalten sich einfach äh talibanartig, ja, indem sie uns hier einfach äh nicht äh priorisieren.
Vor allem da wo ich gerade bin, sind die Taliban wirklich nicht fern. Da sollte der äh Oettinger mal äh gucken, wie das hier so ist.
Ja und hier ist es äh ist auch absolut lebenswichtiger Inhalt, der hier äh übermittelt wird und und das ist ja jetzt wohl mal ganz klar, ja, dass,
die Bengels in Brüssel, dass ich da mal ein bisschen zurückhalten äh müssen, damit wir jetzt hier unsere äh politischen Forderungen ohne Verzögerung an die Bedürftigen tragen können.
So sieht's doch aus.
Weil wir ja auch davor warnen müssen, dass hier plötzlich einer von rechts kommt.
Da kommt einer von rechts. So sieht's nämlich aus. Womit wir jetzt haben wir jetzt, ne, haben wir jetzt vor gewarnt.
Ach ja.
Okay. Ah, jetzt kommen wir, glaube ich.
Jetzt kommen wir noch zu einem kleinen äh Teilerfolg äh auch deiner Aktivität. Ich weiß nicht, ob das immer so gerechtfertigt ist, sei da ähm,
äh deinem Tun und Treiben äh jetzt so ohne weiteres äh zuzuschreiben, aber es ist zumindest related und äh es fällt in einen äh Bereich, den du ja schon sehr aktiv äh beackert hast im letzten Jahr, nämlich die E-Mail, wo
der größte Kritikpunkt, ja, immer derjenige war, dass äh,
Die Verschlüsselung, nicht eine Ende zu Endeverschlüsselung ist, sondern dass ja bei den äh Zwischenspeicherern, also da, wo ja sozusagen die Mail vorüber ab äh vorübergehend abgelegt wird, bevor sie dem eigentlichen,
Adressaten zugestellt werden kann, dass er dort unverschlüsselt wäre, weil das müsste ja so sein, damit man sie auf Viren prüfen kann, damit das irgendwie alles total,
sicher ist und natürlich kann man diesen Providern wunderbar vertrauen, wie gut äh das mit diesem Vertrauen und den Providern,
funktioniert. Das haben wir ja nun im letzten Jahr mit den ganzen Snowdenfiles gesehen an dieser Kritik scheint dieses Projekt auch ziemlich äh erstick,
u sein, also vielleicht nicht unbedingt nur an der Kritik, es gab ja auch ansonsten relativ wenig Gründe, das zu benutzen. Äh umso interessanter ist es, dass jetzt in der Debatte auf einmal
Ankündigungen auftaucht. Ich weiß es gar nicht, wie konkret ist das jetzt schon? Ist das nur so ein Vorschlag oder ist das tatsächlich schon eine Ankündigung des Treibens, dass man ja jetzt irgendwie GPG oder PGP in dieses System hineininizieren möchte, um diese Ende zur Endeverschlüsselung dann doch wieder äh herzustellen?
Ja, ja. Also
um jetzt nicht nochmal diese gesamte D-Mail äh Geschichte auszurollen, war vor allem in der letzten Sendung ja schon drüber gesprochen haben, verweise ich jetzt einfach nochmal auf den äh Vortrag, den ich beim beim dreißig C drei zu dem Thema gehalten habe, da war das ja
eigentlich schon ähm ein ein alter Schuh so ein bisschen, da waren dann die Gesetzesänderungen schon durch, in denen,
ähm TD Mail als bevorzugtes Mittel für die Kommunikation mit den Gerichten und den Behörden etabliert werden sollte,
Wir haben in der letzten Sendung nochmal darüber gesprochen, ähm dass trotz massiver Bewerbung dieses Produkt immer noch keine.
Kritische Anzahl an Nutzern erreicht hat. Ähm und jetzt kam am Anfang dieser Woche die Meldung, äh D-Mail,
Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung. So. Ihr habt ihr habt's gefordert, wir richten's ein
so also die Anbieter haben offensichtlich gesehen so, okay wir schieben den Leuten die Zalando-Gutscheine und die Amazon-Gutscheine und die Lufthansa-Meilen und die Freiminuten und den und den den
gib es nicht alles noch für Gutscheine, die man heute irgendwie den Leuten in den Arsch schieben muss und trotzdem kriegen wir einfach die, die melden sich einfach nur an, nehmen den, nehmen den Schuhgutschein
und äh nutzen den Scheiß nicht und wir müssen dieses Ding jetzt irgendwie mal an den an den Start bringen, weil wir haben ja viele, viele Millionen investiert und
all das haben wir alles schon besprochen und jetzt hat die Marketingabteilung offensichtlich gesagt, ja ähm hör mal, äh mach doch mal Ende zu Ende.
Und dann und dann haben die sich gesagt, ja okay, dann machen wir jetzt Ende zu Ende.
Jetzt muss man das so sehen. D-Mail ist, wie gesagt, eine ein sehr langer, großer, eine sehr lange, große Spezifikation, wie man einen E-Mail-Server so, so sicher wie möglich,
konfiguriert, den Server wohlgemerkt.
Und dann auch noch in kompatibel Macht mit allen anderen E-Mail-Servern, obwohl das eigentlich nicht notwendig wäre. So, dann.
Und in dieser riesigen Spezifikation steht eben nichts von einer Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung.
Und der Hinweis, den ich damals immer gebracht habe und der Hauptkritikpunkt war, dass ich gesagt habe, Freunde,
Wir leben in einer Welt, in der es seit seit vielen Jahren bald ein Vierteljahrhundert, ja, ich ich springe da, ich überspringe jetzt zwei Jahre, also PGP ist jetzt, glaube ich, so dreiundzwanzig Jahre alt. Bald ein Vierteljahrhundert gibt es diese schöne Technik.
Und sie findet keinerlei Verbreitung, weil,
sie nicht als Standard in unsere Kommunikationssysteme integriert ist. Wir müssen uns immer nochmal ein Plugin,
in unseren van bauen, wir müssen uns ein Plug-in in unser Apple Mail bauen wir.
Wir bekommen einfach keine standardmäßige Ende zu Endeverschlüsselung ab Werk. Das hat.
Einerseits auch ganz gute Gründe, weil die Idee einer Ende zu Endeverschlüsselung natürlich ist, dass sie,
abhängig, unabhängig ist von dem Medium, über das man sie spricht,
Ja, also D-Mail konnte schon immer Ende zu Ende verschlüsseln, genauso wie jedes andere Kommunikationsmedium auch, ja? Ich kann Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte Nachrichten,
übers Telefon austauschen oder über ein Brief. Es ist nur sehr umständlich.
Und deswegen sind die meisten Briefe, die wir schicken, eben auch nicht Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt, weil es sehr schwierig wäre, dass äh einmal zu zu implementieren und zu standardisieren. Was jetzt in den letzten Jahren geschehen ist.
Ist das ähm uns Systeme geschenkt wurden, die in den Client
schon einfach eine Ende zu Endeverschlüsselung eingebaut haben. Schöne Beispiele ist also dieses äh Textsecure und das in Deutschland ja auch sehr beliebte Threema, wo im Prinzip einfache Instant Messenger-Systeme.
Laufen und in dem Client automatisch,
die Fähigkeit zu Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung integriert ist, während die Fähigkeit nicht Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte Nachrichten zu versenden, gar nicht erst existiert.
Und,
somit brauchst du kein Plugin mehr und das ist genau das, wofür ich seit Jahren plädiere, baut die Systeme bitte so, dass es den unverschlüsselten Fall gar nicht mehr gibt.
Aus einer technischen Perspektive muss ich jetzt natürlich schon anmerken, es ist schon wichtig, dass die.
Der Teil, der die Ende zu Endeverschlüsselung macht, aus einer von der Plattform unabhängigen Instanz kommt.
Die vor allem quell offen ist, damit du sichergehen kannst, dass nicht der Schlüssel äh nochmal gelegt wird oder so. Aber von genau dieser reinen Lehre, ich hatte vor ein paar Sendungen schon mal davon gesprochen, müssen wir uns, glaube ich, einfach nach,
fast einem Vierteljahrhundert jetzt mal ähm lossagen.
Und sagen, okay, was wir wollen, was wir brauchen, ist Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung in die Breite. Und für alle,
indem wir sie einfach zum Standard erheben. Und da kommt es jetzt auch nicht mehr darauf an, dass diese Ende zu Endeverschlüsselung so implementiert ist, dass wir damit einen Edward Snowden schützen können, denn wir wollen einfach erstmal die Grundbevölkerung,
die Basisbevölkerung schützen, die ähm äh einfach mal.
Verschlüsselt und sicher kommunizieren kann. Vertraulich kommunizieren kann, ohne dass sie einigermaßen Überwachung verschiedener internationaler Geheimdienste äh zum Opfer fällt,
Und das war genau mein Argument immer bei der D-Mail, dass ich gesagt habe, baut das bitte von vorneherein ein. Haben sie nicht gemacht? Haben, ist ihnen das Ding auf die Füße gefallen und jetzt gehen sie hin und sagen, okay.
Wir bauen Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung ein. Und jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wie? Und zwar nehmen sie ein,
Ein Plug-in für den Chrom Browser, das ähm.
Quasi im Browser ein ein Plug-in ist und das dann auch mit D-Mail funktioniert.
Dieses, dieses Plug-in ist äh geschrieben von ähm Thomas äh Thomas Obernörfer. Ähm,
Angefangen hat er damit zweitausendzwölf. Ich kenne den Thomas auch, falls er uns zuhört, äh schöne Grüße, guter Mann. Der entwickelt seit ähm einiger Zeit
an diesen, an dieser Open Extension äh für den für den Browser. Was keine schlechte Idee ist.
In einer Welt, in der deine ähm deine Anbieter.
Ende zu Endeverschlüsselung nicht unterstützen. Und er hat zum Beispiel dieses Plug-in halt so geschrieben, dass, wie gesagt, ist ein Chrome Plugin, da ist ein ist ein kompletter PGP-Stick drin und
Gleichzeitig erkennt dieses Plug-in zum Beispiel, wenn du jetzt auf einer Gmail-Seite bist, auf einer Jahu-Mail GMX Outlook Dot com Seite, erkennt es dann schon mal die,
Webseite und versucht sich so schön wie möglich da rein zu integrieren. Also hier eine eine Lösung, die.
Elegant ist, die in Ordnung ist, aber deren einzige Notwendigkeit ähm daher existiert, weil wir eben nicht.
In den Kommunikationsdiensten, die wir nutzen, von vorneherein diese Möglichkeit finden.
Also, sie fallen jetzt genau auf dieses Problem zurück, dass wir, dass die Nutzer, die über eben über D-Mail Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt kommunizieren wollen, ein Plug-in installieren müssen in ihrem Browser.
Was der größere Teil der Nutzer nämlich nicht tun wird und der Teil der Nutzer, der es tut, kann dann wieder nicht mit allen kommunizieren und lässt es dann eben auch sein.
Gleichzeitig stellt sich die Frage, ob und wie sie.
Die ähm die Schlüsselverwaltung machen, also ob sie wenigstens sich die Mühe gemacht haben, in ihre D-Mail-Oberfläche sowas wie eine,
Vertraute Instanz für PGP-Schlüssel zu,
einzubauen, die automatisch sagt, ey, du schreibst jetzt grade äh eine E-Mail an den an den Thomas. Äh wunderbar. Dann nimmst du direkt den Key hier,
und schickst die Nachricht raus. Meine Vermutung ist, aber da kann ich, wie gesagt, nur sagen, dass ich da jetzt grade vermute.
Wenn sie schon sich an einer Open-Source-Lösung äh bedienen, die übrigens von verschiedenen äh.
NGOs und ähm GOs äh gefahndet wurde, ähm um quelloffen äh eben der der Menschheit zur Verfügung zu stehen, dann werden sie sich auch nicht die Mühe machen, die noch großartig anzupassen. Ähm,
Das heißt, sie haben da jetzt gesehen, ach da gibt's ja was, äh von von Open Source, was ja auch nicht verkehrt ist, wie gesagt, wir wollen ja auch äh was haben bei dieser Krypto, aber der das Problem, was sie hier haben, es ist halt so eine,
von hinten durch die Brust ins Auge lösung, die.
Für das Problem, was sie löst, sehr elegant ist, aber eben nicht das Problem löst, dass wir dass die äh die Nutzung der Ende zu Endeverschlüsselung,
an der mangelnden Verbreitung krankt. Und das heißt, ähm letztendlich,
bedienen Sie sich hier an einem an einem Open-Source-Projekt, der der Community ähm hacken das irgendwie zurecht, dass es äh dass es in Ihr System integriert werden kann, das ist vielleicht ein
ein paar Tage bis in ein paar Wochen Arbeit, wenn man dann noch die Testzeiten mit dazu nimmt äh und haben dann äh die Hoffnung,
dass eben überall dieser Einwand der fehlenden Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung ausgeräumt ist.
Und die Piratenpartei hat da eine sehr schöne äh Pressemitteilung zu ich wurde natürlich, weil ich
wenn man den Namen und Ende zu Ende googelt, dann kommt, fällt da relativ schnell mein Name äh und auch der des Compost Computerclubs. Ich würde da auch von äh einigen,
Journalisten zu interviewt.
Habe da eben auch meine ähm meinen Teil dazu gegeben, deswegen zitiere ich natürlich jetzt äh an dieser Stelle mal die Piratenpartei, äh die gesagt hat,
D-Mail bleibt eben auch,
mit Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung ein ein totes Pferd, weil sie eben nicht pertiphaltrin ist, ja? Das heißt, dieser schöne, dieses schöne Beispiel,
ähm ähm wie war das, wie war's nochmal.
Jetzt fällt mir das Beispiel nicht ein. Egal, stattdessen zitiere ich einen sehr schönen Tweet, den ich im im Internet gelesen habe, wo jemand sagte, ähm du kannst auch
über eine Brieftaube endet zu Ende verschlüsselt, kommunizieren, aber dann ist es halt kein Feature der Brieftaube,
und genau das ist hier äh jetzt mit dem mit der mit dem Anbieten eines eines Open Force Plug-ins zur zur freien Installation in dein D-Mail eine äh genau der Fall.
Ja, ist das wirklich
absurd, ja, also jetzt hat man wirklich nach einer vielen, vielen Jahren das Offensichtliche zur Kenntnis genommen, ja, was ihn auch schon tausendmal äh um die Ohren gehauen wurde, was sie aber bisher immer getrost ignoriert haben, weil irgendwie war das ja nicht so wichtig. Jetzt nach dieser ganzen öffentlichen Debatte und vor allem, nachdem sich äh weiter einstellenden äh Gesamtversagen dieses,
und der mangelnden Attraktivität so, vor allem, ne, jetzt wo die ganzen Zalando-Gutscheine weg sind,
wollen sie vielleicht auch mal wirklich User sehen, die das System benutzen? Ich weiß nicht, ob da überhaupt irgendwelche Zahlen schon bekannt geworden sind, aber ich habe so ein bisschen die Vermutung, würden diese Zahlen bekannt werden, dann wär's nochmal so ein richtiger Schenkelklopfer, weil ehrlich gesagt, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das überhaupt,
irgendeine nennenswerte Aktivität hat dieses Netzwerk. Also wenn da schon vier, wenn die schon vierstellige Nutzerzahlen haben, dann wäre ich schon echt überrascht.
Echt überrasch.
Also na ja, sie haben ja Nutzerzahlen haben sie. Äh da da war ja letztens diese Zahl von einer Million, die ja schon lächerlich.
Angemeldete Accounts.
Ja, genau. Theoretisch durch DML erreichbare.
Ne, ich rede jetzt wirklich verschickte E-Mails
ja? Beziehungsweise wie wie viele Menschen sozusagen, wie viele einzelne Menschen mindestens eine äh die E-Mail verschickt haben, die nicht irgendwie eine Test-Mail war. Sondern die wirklich so ein, ich kommuniziere mit meinem Finanzamt oder was auch immer.
Das Absurde ist ja, dass man,
Was wollte man denn eigentlich haben? Man wollte einen verbindliches System, was irgendwie sicher ist, ja, was die Leute auch benutzen, damit man irgendwie mit den Behörden kommunizieren kann. Und wäre ja auch toll,
Jetzt sozusagen stellt sie zusätzlich noch die Erkenntnis ein, da wäre auch noch ganz super, wenn das sozusagen äh nicht nur die Identität sicherstellt, sondern äh äh wenn's auch noch verschlüsselt wäre, weil wir haben jetzt irgendwie äh genug in den Computerzeitschriften gelesen, dass es doch wohl an sich eine ganz tolle Idee wäre.
Da kann ich nur sagen, wozu habt ihr diesen Scheißdreck überhaupt erfunden? Das gibt's alles schon. Ja, es gibt irgendwie.
Ja natürlich. Da ist ja auch nichts erfunden.
Es gibt Mailsystem, das existiert seit dreißig Jahren. Da ist irgendwie äh äh vor allem Verschlüsselungs- und Identifizierungsmechanismus, den man problemlos jetzt äh hätte kombinieren können. Warum gehe ich nicht zu meinem
Bürgeramt oder was auch immer, lege da meinen äh meinen Pass oder mein mein Perso auf den Tisch und dann kriege ich halt äh ein entsprechendes
Zertifikat zugeteilt. Das installiert man irgendwie in seiner Software und die Sache ist irgendwie fertig.
Es wäre ja vor allem möglich gewesen. Es wäre ja sogar möglich gewesen. Du kannst ja so ein in den.
Aber ja, aber stimmenst du mir nicht zu, dass das im Prinzip schon ausgereicht hätte?
Es natürlich, das war auch einer der einer der Vorschläge, die ich damals gemacht habe, habe gesagt, haut doch einfach schöne, schöne Zertifikate in die neuen Personalausweise, ja, dann habt ihr zwei Fliegen mit einer Klappe, dann können eure Nutzer,
richtig schön mit ihrem Personalausweis signieren. Überlegt mal, was das alles für ein was das alles für ein ähm,
für einen Gewinn gebracht hätte, ja, dann könntest du dir äh wenn du da irgendwie
was ist, wenn man eine Kreditkarte beantragt oder so oder ein Konto, dann muss man doch immer dieses Post-Ident-Verfahren machen
Das hättest du dir alles sparen können, da hättest du sagen können, okay und jetzt nehmt ihr das PDF hier mit euren Daten drin
äh und äh signiert das einmal mit eurem Perso und äh geschenkt ist so und dann ist gut. So, dann hast du also da, da könntest du richtig geilen Scheiß machen und
vor allem haben sie ja sogar die Gesetze dafür schon, weil sie dieses Signaturgesetz damals geändert haben und es gibt ja Signatur Karten,
dummerweise ähm hängen da natürlich auch wieder Personen oder oder Interessengruppen drin, die sagen, ah wunderbar, da wollen wir aber gerne Geld mit verdienen.
Ähm und du kannst zum Beispiel, wenn ich das jetzt recht entsinne, theoretisch zur zur Sparkasse gehen und dir auf dem auf dem Smartcard-Chip deiner EC-Karte äh ein Signatur-Zertifikat-Zertifikat deployen lassen,
Das geht. Und damit kannst du dann mit so einem Kartenleser äh dann äh signieren.
Das geht. Machen einige einige äh Rechtsanwälte und Notare wohl. Äh weil sich das auch nur Rechtsanwälte und Notare leisten können, wenn Schweinegeld kostet. So, aber du, ne, schön wäre natürlich gewesen, okay.
Alle Bürger kriegen das und können Ende zu Ende verschlüsseln. Als Empfänger und signieren als Absender. Schönes zerrt oft auf dem Perso Thema erledigt, ja.
Genau, vor allem bei S-Bahn muss man noch nicht mal groß was lernen, ne? Das Zertifikat da ist, wird das halt einfach benutzt. Und auf einmal wäre auch die gesamte private Kommunikation äh der Menschen untereinander ganz automatisch einfach mal so eben verschlüsselt.
Wer äh also das ist ähm einer der Punkte, warum ich natürlich auch immer äh,
plädiere, wenn es um um Ende zu Ende Verschlüsselung bei E-Mail geht. Aber vielleicht wollen wir da jetzt nicht nicht in die Details nochmal gehen.
Ähm ich habe so viel über über E-Mail-Verschlüsselungen in den letzten Tagen wieder gesprochen,
Wie gesagt, das Traurige ist, es ist wieder nur ein Marketing-Gag und es ist halbherzig umgesetzt, ja und ähm das ist halt bei diesem Produkt so. Und äh sie hatten aber auch keine andere Gelegenheit mehr, ja. Also ich meine, das Ding ist durchgespeckt. Es
steht quasi dran, worauf der, der, der, der freundliche Herr vom BSI achtet, wenn er deinen dein D-Mail-System abnimmt.
Und ähm so ist es halt. Und das genau deshalb greifen sie ja jetzt auch auf so eine äh auf so eine äh Plugin-Lösung zurück und das tun ja auch, okay, jetzt war das nicht so schwer, da mussten sich halt alle,
D-Mail-Anbieter in Deutschland zusammentun und sich darauf einigen, dass sie das machen. Alle sind in dem Fall, glaube ich, drei. Also ist, glaube ich, Telekom Telekom,
eins und eins und United Internet oder so.
Weil ein Gipfeltreffen.
Gipfeltreffen der DMA. Ja, es ist echt ja. Andererseits, ja,
habe ich auch drüber nachgedacht. Es ist halt äh ein,
vielleicht ein einer meiner ersten oder meiner eindringlichsten politischen, politischen Erfolge, dass das, dass ich mich jetzt zurücklehnen kann und sagen kann, seht ihr, habe ich euch doch gesagt.
Genau. Und eine zwei äh zwei Jahre machen sie vielleicht sogar genau das, was du sagst.
Was was passieren wird, ist folgendes. Ähm das möchte ich jetzt noch schnell vorwegnehmen.
Ein paar Leute werden dieses Plug-in installieren, die anderen nicht, weil es ihnen zu kompliziert ist. Die wenigen Leute, die es installiert haben, werden dann damit niemanden erreichen können.
Und werden es sein lassen. Und dann werden sie auf Nachfrage in einem Jahr ähm eine Statistik rausgeben,
und sagen, seht ihr, haben wir doch immer gesagt, die Nutzer wollen kein Ende zu Ende, weil es zu kompliziert ist. Gut, dass wir nicht auf den Neumann gehört haben und das zum Standard gemacht haben.
Und das ist natürlich genau das Verquere, ja, also es schaut man muss sich die Dienste anschauen, dies die vernünftige Clans gebaut haben, die es von vornherein eingebaut haben und die erfreuen sich großer Beliebtheit, weil sie ist nutzerfreundlich und einfach gemacht haben.
Ja GPG ist an der Stelle halt auch problematisch. Ich meine, das mag einen, ein lange etablierter
Dienst sein, aber er ist halt bis heute eigentlich nur für Leute wirklich nutzbar, die genau wissen, was sie tun und die vor allem äh diese Schlüsselaustausch äh Prozedur in irgendeiner Form beherrschen. Und das ist halt so dieses dieses Kernproblem. Es gibt ja auch
ich will das jetzt auch nicht weiter vertiefen, aber die Frage ist ja hier auch, wo kommt denn jetzt bitte der Schlüssel her? Ja.
Da bin ich natürlich noch sehr gespannt.
Wie komme ich irgendwie überhaupt an diese öffentlichen Schlüssel mit denen ich da kommunizieren muss, weil die müssen ja irgendwie auf meinen Computer übertragen werden, also muss es irgendeinen Keyserver geben, wer betreibt
den, ja, wo es da jetzt wiederum die äh das das Vertrauen begründet, dass dass mir da nicht falsche Schlüssel untergeschoben werden, also
völlig unklar.
Das, das ist da bin ich gespannt, wenn dann irgendwann mal jemand mir berichten wird, wie sie es umgesetzt haben, aber äh was noch ganz witzig ist,
Sie sie schießen sich da an einer Stelle relativ übel in den Fuß und zwar gilt ja die D-Mail als zugestellt. Ähm.
Hatte ich auch ausführlich erklärt, so so eine D-Mail wird abgesandt und wenn der, damit gilt sie als zugestellt. Thema erledigt. Es gibt die, du musst halt quasi dein D-Mail-Postfach regelmäßig lesen, weil wenn du darüber irgendeine Anwalts
bekommt. Und das ist ja das einzige, was wir darüber am Ende wirklich bekommen wirst, irgendwelche Post, die zu deinem Nachteil gereicht
Ja, da wirst du ja nicht irgendwie äh gute Nachrichten drüber bekommen, sondern eben irgendwelche Gerichtsscheiße, die mit mit äh.
Reagiert sie sofort, sonst du.
Reagieren Sie sofort, sonst fänden wir Ihr Pferd oder so, ne? Und ähm,
oder wir nehmen ihnen ihr Geld weg oder wir kommen rein und kleben irgendwie einen Kuckuck auf ihren Fernseher oder so, ne. Sowas kriegst du ja nachher.
Äh aber jetzt kommt der Witz. Wenn die jetzt Ende zu Ende verschlüsseln, ja? Und sie haben.
Sehr stark beteuert. Ich habe dann auch allen Journalisten gesagt, fragt mal, was passiert, wenn man das Passwort zu dem Kiefer gibt
weil das wäre natürlich jetzt schön, ja? Also ich meine, was passiert dann, wenn wenn dann sagt, na ja, dann, wenn ihr das Passwort zu dem Kiefer äh vergesst, dann kriegt ihr halt einen Neuen, ja
Äh neues Passwort, dann weißt du, wie wie gut die Ende zu Endeverschlüssung ist. Wenn sie aber sagen, dein Schlüssel ist dann, dein Kies dann eben verloren, dann brauchen sie eine Roll-over-Prozedur dafür, dass sie dir einen neuen Key geben, den Alten irgendwie revoken,
und so weiter, was für sie natürlich mitm mitm kleinen Problem einhergeht. Und jetzt stelle dir einen Nutzer vor, der Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt, eine ähm,
eine Nachricht kriegt, die gerichtsfest als zugestellt gilt, er aber den Schlüssel,
das Kennwort zu dem Schlüsselpass vergessen hat und deswegen diese Nachricht nicht lesen kann.
Selber schuld.
Bin ich.
Aber diese Fragen werden sich halt nie stellen, weil das wird halt das wird halt keine Verbreitung finden und deswegen sind das jetzt hier wirklich äh theoretische.
Äh ja, was heißt denn hier? Sie wussten nicht, dass ihr Planet zerstört wird. Die Pläne hingen noch mehrere Jahre, nur wenige Lichtjahre entfernt aus. Also.
Ach ja.
Gott. Ja, es ist wirklich, es ist, es ist wirklich hanebüchen und ich.
Schau doch auch immer wieder, ob dieser geballten, Inkompetenz in in Führungsetagen. Das ist, glaube ich, auch überhaupt so ein Problem. Ist ja nicht so, dass wir niemanden hätten in Deutschland, der irgendwie diese Sachen versteht.
Ist ja nicht so, dass es niemanden gibt, der irgendwie das schneit. Aber diese Leute befinden sich einfach nicht an den Stellen, wo solche Maßnahmen dann auch wirklich strategisch
beschlossen werden. Ich sage jetzt nicht irgendwie Politik, aber es würde ja vielleicht auch schon mal reichen, wenn in den Unternehmen so wie Telekom oder so.
So etwas Gewicht hätte, dass man, dass man, dass man auch eine ähm, wie soll ich sagen, so eine Art.
Technologie-Verifikationsprozedur äh hat oder so eine Instanz hat, dass man sich sicher ist, dass man da keine Scheiße erzählt.
Das findet offensichtlich irgendwie nicht statt. Wenn ich mir das übertrage, stell mal vor, Google oder Apple würde mit.
Diesem Grad an Professionalität agieren und ihre Systeme zusammenschrauben. Da würde doch nichts laufen.
Nichts. Diese ganze Infrastruktur all diese ganzen Datacenter weltweit, die sie da betreiben,
Es würde einfach alles explodiert und ihre ganze Sicherheit ist ist klarer, ja? Einzige Vergleich, den mir da noch einfällt, also der so ähnlich katastrophal ist, sind hier so so Sachen wie Lenovo, ne, mit ihrer mit ihrer Spyware. Wo man sich irgendwie so fragt,
wie kann sowas überhaupt auf einem,
Entscheiderlevel überhaupt auch nur erwogen werden, dass man so etwas macht. Weil die natürlich ganz offensichtlich von diesen ganzen Konsequenzen keine Ahnung haben und und da herrscht irgendwie noch so eine,
eine Dummheit, ich meine, dass jemand, der jetzt ein Unternehmen managt,
darüber jetzt im Detail kein technisches Know-How haben kann oder muss,
geschenkt. Aber man muss Prozeduren haben, wie man die Leute, die die das wirklich bewerten können und dafür irgendwie auch ihre Hand ins Feuer äh legen,
man die in solche Entscheidungsprozeduren auch mit einbindet, nachvollziehbar einbindet,
Das findet irgendwie nicht statt. Und da da fehlt es irgendwie einfach auch an an Basis in diesem Land.
Das stimmt, ich muss nur nochmal kurz darauf hinweisen, also D-Mail ist halt ein relativ fest definierter Standard und sie konnten da jetzt, also es gab jetzt auch keine elegante Lösung mehr, das da irgendwie vernünftig reinzubauen. Das geht halt nicht.
Nee, aber das ist aber, ja, aber schon schon am Anfang
Hätte man sagen sollen, ja. Stattdessen standen sie da alle so Förderkohle, Förderkohle, geil. Aber die die langfristigen Auswirkungen
auch für einfach für den Standort. Deutschland, für Europa, irgendwie letzten Endes auch für die Beteiligten Unternehmen. Ich meine, jedes Unternehmen, was an diesem ganzen dem Kasperkram äh mitgemacht hat, die haben sich doch einfach, die blamieren sich doch einfach,
X und so was.
Blamage ist den.
Nehme ich doch einfach nicht ernst diese Läden.
Das stimmt, aber Blamage ist für die, glaube ich, das kleinere Problem. Ich glaube, die sind alle jetzt auch relativ traurig, weil äh das schöne Geld weg ist,
auf keinen grünen Zweig mehr kommen. Aber okay, wir müssen mal äh uns den den nächsten traurigen Botschaft ähm äh zuwenden.
Gut, äh machen wir das so. Äh ich meine noch vielleicht eine Sache mit das schöne Geld ist weg, aber der Punkt ist,
Das nächste bekloppte Förderprojekt der Bundesregierung ist doch nur eine Frage der Zeit.
Dieser Prozess, der geht auch immer wieder von vorne los. Jetzt kommt wird irgendwas wird jetzt wieder
was auch immer die die Sau ist die als nächstes durch die Straße getrieben wird, ja? Keine Ahnung, irgendwann merken sie das mit dem Glasfaser, Breitbandausbau lässt sich jetzt dann doch nicht vermeiden
Die ganze Zeit haben sie irgendwie Kupfer und bla und irgendwann stellen sie fest, ach wir hätten eigentlich schon immer mal Kabel irgendwo äh Glasfaserkabel verbuddelt sollen. Die Schweizer machen das schon irgendwie seit über zehn Jahren, läuft super
jetzt machen wir das auch. So und dann geht's los und dann dann kommen wieder diese ganzen großen Firmen, ah, schwierig und so weiter, da müssen wir ja erstmal nochmal uns was ausdenken und so, weißt du und dann wird wieder irgend so ein Fördertopf aufgemacht, da wird wieder irgendeine,
beschissene technische Lösungen gemacht werden, die am Ende überhaupt nicht funktioniert, wo Millionen verballert werden, anstatt einfach mal es macht mich einfach glücklich,
fertig, ist schlimm.
Ja, die Dinge werden nicht richtig gemacht.
Okay, nächstes und letztes Thema, ja, ne?
Ja, ähm es mehren sich die Meldungen. Also es gab's irgendwie erstmal vor ein paar Tagen schon auf Spiegel Online äh dann wurde
widersprach Heiko Maas, dem aber wieder im Spiegel war das ähm dann widersprach, Heiko Maas, dem aber,
Fakt ist wohl.
Dass ähm der Thomas de Maizire, unser Innenminister, ähm inzwischen wieder in Gesprächen ist mit unserem Justizminister Heiko Maas. Ähm wie man denn.
Konstruktiv und zielorientiert ähm auf eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung hinwirken könnte. Die Rheinische Post,
sagt, das generelle Nein der SPD zur Speicherung von Kommunikationsdaten sei schon vom Tisch. Ähm,
Sigmar Gabriel bezeichnet die Vorratsseitenspeicherung schon als ein unter Umständen geeignetes Instrument. Ähm Union hat ein bisschen mit dem Abspecken ihrer Förderung, äh ihrer Forderungen begonnen und ähm,
beide Seiten beschimpfen sich da in der Öffentlichkeit nicht mehr so sehr. Das heißt, es sieht danach aus, dass sie sich jetzt halt irgendwie langsam äh einigen wollen. Ähm.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was da am Ende draus wird. Ähm.
In den Berichten wird davon gesprochen, dass sie sich darüber Gedanken machen würden,
ähm die Anlässe des Zugriffs äh irgendwie genau zu definieren und,
vor allem irgendwie ausnahms ausnahmsregelung für äh herausgehobene Berufsgeheimnisträger äh,
zu definieren, wie zum Beispiel für Anwälte, Ärzte und äh Priester. So dass die irgendwie quasi ein äh ein,
sagen können, hier äh ich bin Anwalt, hier ist meine meine Urkunde, ähm mein mein Anschluss bitte ohne Vorratsdatenspeicherung oder so.
Journalisten nicht.
Äh Journalisten, ich weiß nicht, ob Journalisten als äh Berufsgeheimnisträger gelten, ich glaube nicht, oder?
Naja, was schwierig ist ja schon die Definition eines Journalisten. Das ist ja nun mal kein geschützter Beruf. Journalist kann sich ja äh jeder äh äh nennen, sogar wir, würden wir ja dann auch, aber äh genauer darum.
Fallen die wahrscheinlich hinten runter.
Ja, aber genau darum geht's ja nun gerade, ne?
Aber es gibt halt da jetzt nix, nix wirklich Konkretes, ja, also ähm Heiko Maas hat dann irgendwie das dementiert und hat gesagt.
Deutschland, Deutschland plant kein nationalen Alleingang bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Ähm.
Und es gibt keine äh Verhandlung zwischen Justiz und Innenministerium. Äh er würde seit einem Jahr über mehr als einem Jahr mit Thomas de Maizire regelmäßig reden. Ähm und es gäbe nichts Neues.
Ja. Tja.
War's dann auch schon.
Verweist äh auf die EU-Kommission
die ja erstmal evaluieren will, ob es äh zu einer neuen EU-Richtlinie kommen kann, das ist ja auch ein ein ewiges Hin und Her, ja, also ich meine, dass, wenn man einfach mal nur Vorratsdatenspeicherung in letzter Zeit auf Netzen oder Netzpolitik org äh
sucht, dann findet man echt, dass es jede Woche ist dann irgendwie so EU-Rat.
Oder EU-Kommission will wieder.
EU will erstmal keine Vorratsdatenspeicherung, Parlament will so und so Vivian Reding oder also da das geht ja die ganze Zeit hin und her, das ist glaube ich so eine so eine klassische ähm.
Klassische Verwirrungstaktik. Also das ist, glaube ich, auch keine schlechte Taktik, dieses Thema mit.
Also das Thema ohne Neuigkeiten in der Presse zu halten, auf das die allgemeine äh Öffentlichkeit des Themas überdrüssig wird, weißt du?
Also mach's einfach die ganze Zeit, ja, jetzt, oh, hier wieder Vorzeitenspeicherung, nächsten Tag treten alle vor die Presse und sagen, nee, wie, hä, stimmt nicht. Dann machst du fünfmal,
bis sich keiner, bis sich keiner mehr ernst nimmt und dann wartest du, bis irgendwie kurz vor den Sommerferien und knallst den Leuten das um die Ohren. So, also ist jetzt,
Ne, wäre jetzt nicht das erste Mal, äh dass das ein Thema auf auf die Weise ähm durchgesetzt wird in der Öffentlichkeit.
Ja, richtig, ne, anderer, man könnte natürlich jetzt auch etwas softer formulieren, dass sozusagen sie überhaupt diese ganze Debatte äh als solche erstmal im Raum halten wollen. Allein um dann im richtigen Moment immer die
Gelegenheit zu haben, na ja, wie man ja äh merkt, wir hatten ja unzählige Versuche unternommen und es wurde ja immer wieder äh
niedergestimmt und äh ihr verhindert ja hier die äh erfolgreiche Verbrechensbekämpfung und der übliche Schmerz.
Also mit anderen Worten, es ist eigentlich nichts passiert an der Vorratsdatenspeicherungsfront, sondern es wird einfach nur fleißig äh dementiert.
Ja, aber ich bin da mal gespannt. Also ich ich es würde mich jetzt wundern, wenn da nix käme.
Ja, natürlich. Also irgendwas kommt immer. Ob das jetzt am Ende mit der Meldung zu tun hat oder nicht, aber äh,
Es gibt jetzt echt keinen Anlass davon auszugehen, dass dass wir nicht in nächster Zeit wieder mit irgendeiner Vorratsdatenspeicherung.
Du meinst einfach Holzauge sei wachsam, äh eine dieser Meldungen könnte die Richtige sein, nur weil er jetzt die ganze Zeit einer Löwelöwe schreit. Ja, okay, das äh ist natürlich.
Wie so beim Hütchenspiel, weißt du? Ah, weißte? Wo ist der Gesetzesentwurf? Wo ist der Gesetzesack?
Stimmt. Wie auch immer, wir werden jetzt hier mal äh das Ende einleiten und hast du noch da ähm Wünsche zu verteilen.
Ja, ich ähm danke an dieser Stelle äh Mariano und Hannes und muss eine Person vertrösten, weil ich den Namen grade nicht mit dabei habe.
Bin ähm ja grade nicht zu Haus. Ja.
Ja, bist nicht im Heim. Ich bin auch nicht im Heim. Das war wieder eine Fernaufnahme von äh Lok,
Politik heute auch nochmal mit äh besonderen äh Netzschmerzen, mangels Netzneutralität und ähm zuverlässigen Zugängen. Äh ich hoffe, das wird sich dann innerhalb der nächsten zehn bis fünfzehn Jahre verbessern.
Solange bleibt ihr uns ja sicherlich treu.
Also ich schon.
War ein Jahr. Ja, ich auch. Wir sagen tschüss.
Tschau, tschau.